[Music]
my name is mark van der meulebrucke
i work at duvardis and i just want to
say a few motivating words
on why we're doing what we're doing and
what you can expect to hear today
we start from the inside that graphics
and visuals
are such an important component of the
work we do with quantitative scientists
they're so important for ourselves to
gain insights into data
as well as for communicating results and
conclusions
to our stakeholders and if you've been
following all those coronavirus charts
out there for the past few weeks like i
did
you will agree that graphics are key to
understanding what's going on
unfortunately however we are not always
good at creating
effective graphs how often do we see or
even
create ineffective visualizations
and do we even know which choices or
features
make a graph effective for a particular
purpose or
audience this is our
first focus to convey this understanding
and this point is actually part of a
wider initiative
beyond today's webinar and you will find
the corresponding link
at the end of these slides
secondly once we do know what makes an
effective graph
how easily can we actually implement it
that is created quickly and with minimal
effort
this is our second focus the development
of an r package
that has good graphical principles sort
of built in
building upon many of the great packages
out there and minimizing the code
required for the user
we quickly realized that these themes
are of common interest across
roche novartis and probably many other
companies and institutions
so we've started to team up and tackle
them together
and one of the goals today is also to
call for additional
interested contributors
which leads me to today's agenda
after this introduction my colleague
mark bailey from novartis will speak
about
the principles of effective visual
communication
generally he will then hand over to
shalotta fristenist
and diego saldana from roche who will
focus more specifically
and a bit more technically on the r
package
which we've started to develop
the goal of this package as i said
earlier is to make it really easy to
implement those good principles in
practice
specifically in a healthcare or drug
development context
which is where we work
all this is work in progress and at the
end of the webinar we will
call for further contributors and we
will hopefully also have a few minutes
for q a so with that
mark do you want to start
thank you mark so effective data
visualization
is a key skill for all quantitative
scientists including statisticians
epidemiologists or data scientists
whatever your current title is
traditionally this is a skill
has not been primary a primary focus in
the training and development of
quantitative sciences
in graduate degrees the focus is often
on analytical and technical competencies
this skill of visual communication is
often self-taught
or developed later on in the job
so effective visualization is extremely
important
it is a key skill that allows us to
convey complex concepts and information
to others
if we get this right it helps support
appropriate decisions or actions if we
get this wrong it can lead to
misinformation confusion
or even harm especially in clinical and
medical research
the visualization on the right is a good
recent example of this
covering the current coronavirus
pandemic
the visualization was recently published
in the new york times
it displays the concept of social
distancing and why it is important
it is important because it helps break
the transmission chain
the graphic also illustrates the concept
of exponential growth
this is something we've heard a lot of
recently here we see an infected
individual who goes on to infect two
others
they in turn infect two others until we
begin to see many individuals infected
with the virus
all stemming from a single person by
practicing social distancing we may
break this chain therefore reducing the
number of subsequent
infections which could be substantial as
displayed in the bottom graphic
we are not always good at it on the
right is an example from a clinical
study report
waterfall plots are commonly used to
report treatment response and oncology
clinical trials aesthetically this plot
doesn't look good
from the choice of patterns to the
general look and feel
for me it feels like it was produced by
a typewriter rather than modern software
there's a lot not to like about this
plot but as i said earlier
if we get visual communication wrong it
can lead to the wrong conclusions
and then working in medical and clinical
research this can often result in harm
so apart from the aesthetic limitations
the real failing of this graph is not
the look and feel
but that the graph expects a reader to
make calculations mentally to compare
treatment effects across multiple doses
waterfall plots are often used to
support decision making
especially in critical indications found
in oncology
so asking the reader to make those
calculations mentally isn't an effective
way to communicate
so what do we mean by effective
we don't necessarily mean beautiful so
what do we
so we don't really mean to focus on the
beautiful so to illustrate here
is an example of a visually appearing
peeling graph from david mcanlis
he is a data artist and journalist from
the uk
the visualization is called mountains
out of molehills
a timeline of global media scare stories
the visualization attempts to
investigate the number of news story
reports
and if there is a sense of
over-reporting and so this could
cause unnecessary panic it covers
earlier pandemics such as sars
bird flu and spine flu but also video
games and killer wasps
visually it is appealing and draws you
in but i would argue it's not effective
as key information is hidden away in the
legend
so if you look at the legend there are
numbers and brackets that provide the
deaths associated with each story is
very difficult to see i can imagine this
information is important to determine if
there really is over reporting but the
information is not factored into the
main body of the graph
also the subtitle uses languages such as
scarce stories
it has comparisons to annual seafloo
seasonal flu deaths
and it also has comparisons to topics
such as video gaming
all of these design choices indirectly
influence the reader which can then
influence decision making
so beautiful and effective that's what
we really want so here's an example of a
recent effective visualization published
by the economist
the visualization captures the recent
phrase that we hear a lot of now
flatten the curve the graph summarizes
this concept really well
so we have two distributions over time
which represent the number of infections
in the population
each distribution represents a strategy
strategy one
for not taking preventative measures
such as social distancing
and strategy 2 that does you can see
that strategy 2 reduces the peak of the
distribution through social distancing
this strategy extends epidemic over a
longer period of time
but reduces the peak number of
infections this special visualization is
effective in introducing this concept of
flattening the curve
but can we be even more effective so
here's another version of the same graph
aesthetically it's not as appealing as
the previous one
but by adding a dotted line and a simple
annotation
healthcare system capacity this
visualization now highlights the why
why do we want to flatten the infection
curve and spread an
epidemic over a longer period of time
the purpose of flattening the curve is
not to overwhelm the healthcare system
so the dotted line illustrates that the
first strategy would result in more
infections than the healthcare system
could cope with
this sadly can have terrible
consequences that we're currently
witnessing now
so both graphs are very effective ways
to convey complex concepts to the
population
and getting messages out there and i
just want to highlight that
both of these slides were influenced by
a tweet from cal bergstrom
the link is there if you want to follow
up on it
so effective visualization is effective
visual communication effective graphs
are visually appealing
intuitive legible then use the correct
graph type
and access skills then use proximity and
alignment if facility comparisons
then use labels and annotations to add
clarity to the message as i illustrated
before
and more importantly effective use of
visualizations enable clear and
impactful communication
evaluate our influence with our
stakeholders and facilitate informed
decision making
this is one of the main motivations
behind the collaboration that we are
presenting today
and the initial design of the visa
package
how do we become more effective myself
and colleagues at novartis have been
thinking about this topic for a number
of years
we've tried a number of approaches to
try and address this question
from reading all the literature
available defining best practices
developing galleries of code newsletters
to highlight the importance of the topic
to handing out cheat sheets with and
we've had various levels of success
but to make this concept stick and to be
easier to remember
we recently defined what we call the
three laws for effective visual
communication
have a clear purpose show the data
clearly
and make the message obvious you can
think of these three laws as superheroes
so have a clear purpose this is really
about why do we need this graph
so we should really know the purpose of
creating the graph and this is really
related also to data analysis itself
we should identify the quantitative
evidence to support the purpose
and also identify the audience and focus
the design and to support their needs
show the data clearly this is about
avoiding misrepresentation
choosing the appropriate graph type to
display the data
maximizing data to ink ratio so this is
really just a complex way of saying keep
it simple
finally make the message obvious so
using proximity and alignment to aid in
comparisons
minimize mental arithmetic this has
really gone back to the waterfall plot
where you really don't want the reader
to be doing summations in their head
and using colors and annotations to
highlight important details
so i'll now go through each of these
three laws in more detail
so law one have a clear purpose
this first law is really advanced common
sense
it follows typical planning questions
such as why what who and where
so why do i need a graph and what is its
purpose
is it to explore data or to deliver a
message
what evidence is available to support
this purpose this could be
data sets new experiments simulations
for example
whatever okay who is my intended
audience is it a mix of specialists or
non-specialists or both
you really need to think about who this
audience is and support their needs
and the where where will i publish and
what are the constraints they are
so for the where we may identify certain
formats such as a word document a power
power point presentation or markdown
notebook
or a shiny app and really the design and
the purpose
uh in the principles that we have really
really is important for all of these
different formats but depending on the
format some of these principles may
apply and the
design choices may vary
another aspect to this law is to
identify what are the underlying
questions you're trying to address
so here i've highlighted an article by
roger penn that
discusses his thoughts on john chuki
exploratory data analysis and design
thinking
he argues that better analyses are
related to the quality of the question
so more time spent on defining better
questions is time well spent
and this is related to the famous chooky
quote an approximate answer to the right
question
is worth a great deal more than the
precise answer to the wrong question
so the message here is to spend more
time thinking about your question prior
to
an analysis or designing a visualization
another aspect to this law is why are
you creating visualization
so thinking about this aspect can help
identify the audience and their needs
which in turn helps with the design
so for example if you want to say dig
into data get familiar with the data or
find the story in my data
then the audience is normally you if you
want to communicate the results or to
tell the story
behind the data then the audience is
someone else
so being clear on the purpose is
important here
for example if you're designing a
visualization to be presented
to a group of stakeholders where you
have three minutes to get your
recommendations across
do you really want the audience to play
where's wally
or in the case of america where's waldo
and if you're really interested wally is
in the middle of the
picture here law 2
show the data clearly
the key part of this law is not to lie
or represent with data
try to be open and transparent with your
analysis and the reporting of it
here we have an example from yougov an
important topic of pizza toppings
the visualization displays a pizza pie
chart the visualization is confusing
as the number of numbers add up to way
beyond 100
another thing that's confusing is
mushroom is the uk's most liked pizza
topping
so as a scotsman i really find this hard
to believe
another aspect of this law is to be
transparent here i've displayed a
response from yougov to
clarify the purpose of their chart the
intent was not to display a pie chart
but to present percentages from a survey
here we see that being clear and
transparent builds trust and it helps
with communication
another aspect to this apology is that
it highlights the need to think
carefully about your design
and the graph type
so choosing the correct graph type aids
and interpretation
so thinking about the purpose of the
graph can help identify
appropriate graph types often we don't
need to reinvent the wheel here
for example if we want to show a
deviation a correlation or a ranking
then there are common graph types that
we can select from
another aspect to think about in terms
of graph type
is um how do you what information do you
want to convey
so here's an example of the same data
displayed six different ways
the the path the pi and donut charts and
panels a and b make it difficult to see
the order of magnitude of some of the
segments
that i need to compare areas or angles
these attributes are not easy to compare
the doughnut chart even emits the angles
and bends the areas to make it more
challenging to make these comparisons
the mosaic plot and panel c only relies
on areas
again it's hard to compare across
categories
it is better to use lengths with a
common baseline of positions on a common
scale such as a bar chart or dot plot
the bar chart in panel d though
introduces a fake dimension which is
unnecessary and makes it hard to compare
new numerical values from the height of
the bars
panels e and f are simple and show the
data clearly
they also order the data by magnitude to
aid comparison even further so you're
really
making not making the reader work or do
the
mental arithmetic in their head the dot
plot in panel f uses minimal ink
and draws eye to the position of the
dots so it's probably the most effective
way of displaying the data
choose the right scale for your data so
try to avoid plotting log normally
distributed variables on a linear scale
this can lead to misleading
interpretation especially when you
introduce
lines and code uncertainty so in this
example the uncertainty appears to
increase above 1 which is unity
but this is an artifact of the choice of
the scale using a log scale resolves
this issue
another important aspect related to this
is time and how that is displayed
so space measurements proportional to
the time they were measured
so what do we mean by that so
measurements that are displayed close
together are perceived to be closer in
time
not reflecting this in your
visualization could introduce a visual
bias
so for example slopes or trajectories
may appear steeper
or less so than they are typically are
law three make the message obvious
a key aspect of this law is to assume
that the reader will
not to assume that the reader will
understand what messages information
you're trying to convey
you have to really work at it to get
them to understand this information or
that what you're trying to convey to
them
a simple illustration of this is to try
and not to set text at an angle
think of alternatives such as
transposing the graph so the left-hand
plot
we are essentially asking the reader to
tell their head to read the text
do we really want to give readers next
string
a simple transposon of the graph allows
us to resolve this issue and also
introduces a more effective
visualization also try to avoid
unnecessary color
avoiding color so avoid color
using color to differentiate between
categories of the same variable
this can introduce confusion in a
similar way to the previous pizza
example from yougov
also introducing unnecessary color when
it's not required limits as to when we
really do need to use color later on
for example use color when it adds value
use a bold saturated or contrasting
color to emphasize important details
so the left hand plot horizon naturally
drawn to the top of the bar
the right hand plot we introduce a
contrasting colour
now our eyes are drawn to the bottom of
the bars this is an important design
choice that allows us to highlight key
information and can be used to really
highlight
important messaging and here's an
example of news and annotations and
labels to help with messages
so news labels and annotations to tell
stories about the data and models
on the left hand side we have a typical
dose response plot
by adding annotations such as active
control and target dose on the right
hand side we start to provide more
contextual information for the reader
and then we can start to get to the why
of the plot
so think back to the flattening of the
curve plot where we add in the dotted
line
to indicate the health care system
capacity
so finally here's an example that we
created of a visualization that tries to
follow all three principles
the analysis is a subgroup comparison of
a genetic marker
the analysis is a repeated measures
model of a time we use the title to
indicate a conclusion
or recommendation from the analysis so
genetic marker positive is not predicted
for treatment response
we use annotations to indicate the
direction of the treatment benefit
and we also and we also highlight the
main time point which is our primary
analysis of
week 12 with a dotted circle
instead of legends we use annotations to
indicate each subgroup and we also use
color to differentiate between subgroups
so if you're interested to learn more
about the three laws and some of the
principles i've introduced today
i'd recommend that you visit the website
below graphics principles.github.io
we have a cheat sheet there that
summarizes a lot of these uh principles
and it's developed news in our
there are also other great resources out
there that you can use for example the
the book by
john luke dumont it really introduces
scientific communication it's really an
exemplar book that everyone should read
if you're really interested in data
visualization i would recommend that the
other two books the data visualization
from kieran
haley and also the book by klaus welcome
which focus on not only just
the principles of data visualization but
also how to do this and r
so effective data visualization is
effective visual communication
effective visualizations enable clear
and impactful communication
they evaluate or influence with
stakeholders
and then facilitate informed decision
making to help
design effective visualizations remember
the three laws
purpose clarity and message
so typically now i would do a handover
that would require either a strong or a
moderate handshake
possibly a prolonged high five maybe
just a normal high five
or a prolonged fist pump but given the
the current situation i'll just do a
virtual fist bump to shalotta
chillata thank you mark
so what you've seen in this first
section is how important it is to
implement graphics principles for
effective visual communication
um but the reason why we're giving this
webinar is is that you often
don't see that in typical data science
analyses
and the reason for that is that
implementing those visual principles
can be quite tedious and time-consuming
and adding
quite a bit of extra overhead on the
coding side
so especially early on in projects data
scientists tend to skip
a lot of those principles to just get on
with their project
for example if you look on the right you
can see that creating this relatively
simple dos response curve that's not
even adhering to all the principles that
mark
just described and you see that actually
it requires
as much extra code to style the diagram
and add annotations as it does to plot
the actual data
so because of this extra work we
often skip it but then downstream for
example when communicating to
external stakeholders we have to
keep up with that work and and actually
implement new versions of the plots and
figures and tables that we did in early
on
exploratory projects so
we thought this is something we probably
have to change
if we want to be more effective in the
way we communicate our results and if
you go to the next slide mark
there is actually an additional point
and as mark mentioned we
there are different stakeholders or
different audience to your
reporting outcomes so early on in a
project this might be just for you and
yourself like yourself
and you might remember all the work
you've done or the data manipulations
and you might not need a lot of
additional annotation but
usually you're working in a team at
least in clinical development
and so you have additional stakeholders
that might
look at the outputs that you create
maybe figures or tables
and you might actually have those
stakeholders take those outputs
and then further use them to communicate
their insights
in their teams so it's actually quite
important that
whatever you create in your analyses
cannot be taken out of context
and that at any time it is possible to
reproduce
the output that you created tables and
figures and also trace where the data
came from
so on the right you can see a typical
table shell
for baseline demographics in a cohort
and as you can see clearly we're showing
a table here because mark showed a lot
of figures and we
want to make sure that you all are aware
that outputs can also be tabled
so if you have a table you can see that
there is a lot of metadata
in addition to the actual demographics
that are being
annotated so for example every table and
figure should have a title and it should
name the data source and the version
the data comes from so if that plot
or that table finds its way into
powerpoint presentation
it's easy to trace back where it came
from and
at what time point the analysis was done
we should always have also a part as
part of the rendered object the
information about the abbreviations
and table columns that are being used
the statistical tests that were employed
as well as some baseline information or
basic information about the cohort
such as sample size generally also we
would like
to have the reports that we create to be
harmonized across the different
visualizations
plots and figures again um so that for
example the same treatment
refers is always coded by the same color
in different plots
so there is this second layer in
addition to visual communication
and those graphics principles that mark
just introduced that we often have to
take into consideration
in our data science projects and
again looking at the metadata you can
imagine that
annotating all of these information can
create quite a bit of overhead on the
coding side
and is often skipped early on in
projects
so if you go to the next slide
so we realize this is something we have
to change and
as mark said in the beginning it's it's
probably an issue that not only
data science teams at russian novartis
have but also a lot of other
people doing analytics work across the
industry and beyond
so we thought we want to implement
something like a toolbox that helps us
integrate graphical principles in our
data science and analytics projects
we didn't want to do that in a vacuum
though so we
reached out to not only other data
scientists in our
in our own teams but also important
stakeholders like therapeutic area
scientists or clinical scientists
to better understand what they would
like to see
in typical reports that we create and
what the crucial
aspects are that should never be missing
and with that we came up with a bunch of
development considerations that the
toolbox we wanted to develop
should always adhere to the first one is
really
not creating extra work so it should
integrate seamlessly
into our analytics and reporting
workflows and it should work well
with the tools we are already using so
often this is the analyses are done in r
so it should play well with the tidy
verse
the plotting should probably be done
using ggplot
and then it should be rendered in
different output formats
like our markdown using like html output
as well as sword and latex
or interactively using shiny
um the package or toolbox should be
suitable for
our special use cases in clinical
development
but might also reach beyond and it
should be flexible enough so that also
expert users find
the tools useful and like to use them to
ease some of the coding burden and
create for example these
additional metadata objects around the
visual output they are already creating
as mark said the audience might actually
change for your
for your outputs as a project evolves
and so
the toolbox should allow us to easily
adapt
to these different target audiences
without having to repeat the actual
analysis and that could be for example
by exploring different visualizations of
the same data set
and see which one helps us adhere to
those three
laws that mark introduced especially
which one helps us to make
convey the message clearly and help in
decision making
and as i said the the outputs might make
their way through different stages of
stakeholders as well
so it should be possible to export them
and there was something very
very critical from our teammates in the
on the therapeutic area side
so that you can output them for example
so that they can easily take the output
and present it in their own
presentations and so if you go to the
next slide
this quickly led us to the idea of
developing an
r package because r is increasingly
popular and widely used
in our teams and it already comes with a
bunch of really excellent
existing packages that solve parts of
the problems that we just stated
so there are packages already that allow
very flexible plotting opportunities for
example ggplot
um and we thought actually building on
those
on those packages and standing on the
shoulders of giants here
will make the work less hard for us
the other nice part about using r is
that it is flexible towards multiple
analysis questions and stages of the
workflow
and if we developed a package that had
different functions
we could actually build in the
flexibility that was so requested by our
users
we obviously can have the documentation
and testing
and given that it's open source it's
really easy to collaborate across
companies
and even industries in the future and
contribute content
if you go to the next slide
so that's why we are now presenting
the vista r package in its current form
which is actually
is still very early experimental phase
or you could actually call it a
prototype maybe
which we which we developed and would
like to hear feedback of you all
later on as well we thought to
there were there are a few architecture
considerations we put in
in order to implement those
considerations and requirements that we
got
in our earlier stakeholder interviews so
the first one was really about this
integration seamless integration
into the tidy version our analysis
workflow so we thought
whatever we do it should interact with
the player and the modeling packages
and plotting should be built on ggplot
we also want to keep full transparency
on data modifications
uh first of all for the reproducible
reporting aspect
but also for being able to scale
projects across different stages
and that led us to this decoupled design
that you can see on the right
where we actually take our input data
let's say for example
one row per sample a one row per patient
data set
and then we have dedicated functions
that take care of the data wrangling
and the modeling before another set of
functions
takes care of the visualization
and that visualization ideally adheres
to the graphical principles that mark
just described before and then last but
not least
we have a separate set of functions
again that takes care of the separates
that takes care of the styling of the
outputs
so there shouldn't be any hard-coded
theming for example in the plotting
function but that is then taken care of
and allows us for example to adapt the
visualization to corporate designs
but it also allows us to adapt the
visualization to be consistent across
the report
where for example the treatments are
always
colored in the same way across
we mentioned before as well that in
addition to being flexible though
the coding of and adhering to those
graphical principles
shouldn't add a lot of overhead to the
coding work you're doing as a data
scientist anyways
so we thought it would be great to have
in addition to those individual
decoupled functions the wrapper
functions that allow you
to explore different visualizations for
typical analysis
questions so one typical question in
clinical development when working with a
patient cohort in the beginning
is for example to see how many of those
patients in the data set
adhere to a set of inclusion and
exclusion criteria
and you might want to show the cohort
attrition
and there are different ways of doing
that and diego will talk about it a bit
later
but um having a wrapper function that
allows you to explore these different
visualizations can then help you quickly
find out which visualization might be
the best one to convey your message
clearly to the target audience you're
currently
designing your report for if you go to
the next slide
so this was all very theoretical so far
and it's still going to stay a bit
theoretical for the next two slides
before i hand over to diego
but what i want to show here is really
how this would look if you implemented
it um
for a typical question another typical
question around
time to event analysis and so by having
decoupled functions if we had our
initial input data model
for patient data that has for example an
intervention like treatment
and then the time of follow-up or time
to event
and the status at the end then we
wouldn't
go directly from this input data model
to the plot
but we would go through three individual
steps the first one is really taking
this input data
and have an estimator function that
computes the estimate
in this case the survival model and
after cleaning that with broom we get a
data table
or a typical as an interim
data model which we can then build our
visualizations on
and in this case for example would
contain the time
the stratum as well as the estimates at
different time points
and the confidence intervals and these
can then be easily passed on to ggplot
for example
for visualization as i said before we
didn't want to reinvent the wheel where
this was necessary
so we are building a lot of those
functions on
existing packages of the tidy verse and
beyond
such as broom or in this case also
survival
the idea is by having this multi-tier
approach that you can define a lot of
custom
features that might be required such as
custom time windows
or adding hypothesis tests
and so after you have this interme
interim
data model you have the visualization
function
and then the styling in the end that
helps you allow
to adhere to those graphical principles
that we spoke a bit about before
and so if you go to the next slide
mark
mark can you go to the next slide or is
it stuck just for me okay thank you
so this is these were a lot of the
design considerations that are
definitely not set in stone so if people
have ideas and thoughts about it we
would love to hear them
but diego will show you now in the next
few slides how we implemented the
prototype
and what those outputs look like for now
and with that i would like would like to
hand over to you diego
i'm sure um
[Music]
yeah so so now that charlotta has
introduced
the main architecture considerations and
the main concepts that we use to design
the package
uh let's look at this in the context of
a practical application
so let's look at this in the context of
a time
your typical time to event analysis
workflow
and so when we're carrying out these
types of analysis
analyses um there's a number of steps
that will
be there virtually every time we carry
out these analyses
and all of which require
some level of communicating results
or communicating interim results and
which can be
communicated in different ways depending
on the audience and depending on the
circumstances as
mentioned also by mark before
and so for example you might start with
something like building your analysis
cohort so you might want to understand
how many patients are kept after
applying certain
inclusion exclusion criteria and you
might want to show that by either
showing a table or a flow chart um
then once you have your analysis cohort
you might want to
understand their baseline
characteristics of the population that
you're analyzing
and so you might do that using some kind
of table 1 which is a very popular table
um that's used in virtually all well
in virtually every paper out there on on
these types of studies
and then um you might be interested in
doing some kind of survival analysis
and for that you might plot something
like a couple meyer plot
or you might want to show some tables
showing
immediate survival so there are
different things that you might want to
show
as interim results um and that all
require
a certain level of code um and
programming
and effort and time uh and so we as data
scientists spend a lot of time
doing redoing these a lot of uh uh very
often right um
so can we go to the next slide please
so now let's look at these one by one so
the first one was building an analysis
analysis cohort right um and so first
the philosophy that we have tried to
follow with uh
with bizarre was that we wanted to as
charlotte mentioned uh not create more
work
but we also wanted this to implement
sort of out-of-the-box best practices
and and then also reuse the knowledge
that we have acquired
through our own experience and through
uh interviews that we have uh carried
out
and so the way this works um
as you can see you can create a list of
filters uh as well as descriptions
uh so that's very so it takes very
little code to create your cohort
attrition
um using this r and then really uh
creating um a table that shows the
attrition
just takes basically five lines of code
using this function called vr underscore
render underscore table
and then you can output this nicely
formatted table
that shows you the relevant information
including um
the the criteria that's being applied
what's the condition
how many patients are being kept and
excluded as well as percentages for
these
and of course it comes with nice um i
mean it will show nicely formatted
titles as well as metadata that might be
relevant such as data sources
and so you don't have to spend a lot of
time thinking of what should i show
to the what should i show in this plot
in order to follow best practices again
little code
very little code and nicely formatted
outputs best
folds but best practices and reuses
knowledge
gonna go to the next slide
uh so then you might also want to show
this in the form of a flowchart which is
a very typical
visualization uh the attrition diagram
um and so again this takes very little
code you can create a vector
of complement descriptions um as well as
reuse the outputs from the previous
uh chunk of code and using this
vr underscore attrition function you can
plot this nicely formatted
attrition diagram which shows at each
step how many patients have been kept
and excluded
and this is a very popular again figure
that
shows up in many real world data
analyses
uh papers um and
i should highlight that the that this
type of package can help us
uh better comply with reporting
guidelines like
consort and strobe can we go to the next
slide please
uh so once we have selected our baseline
population and our analysis cohort we
might want to be interested
we might be interested in showing and
understanding the baseline
characteristics
and so this is typically done using the
very popular table 1.
we looked at a number of implementations
of it and we couldn't find one that
really
um satisfied all the requirements that
we had
um so we have created our own um
the nice thing about it is that it's
very flexible
so it comes already with a very
good inbuilt summary functions that will
help you summarize your
categorical as well as numerical
variables
out of the box but it also lets you
input your own
custom build summary functions if they
don't satisfy your specific requirement
it also outputs the tables in different
formats including cable
r studio gt as well as dt html tables
um and importantly it also lets you
download
the table one at excel
or csv which was one of the requests
that came the most often when we
interviewed
our internal scientists
uh and again it takes very little code
it's about four lines of code
um and um again follows
best practices and reuses our uh the
knowledge that we have acquired
can we go to next slide
uh so finally uh we might be interested
or
actually next uh we should we should uh
we might be interested in no no
it's the same yeah um we might be
interested in doing a server
um a survival analysis uh so this is
typically done using a kaplan-meier
curve together with a risk table
and usually um there's a number of
uh metadata elements that are important
here um
and and so i should highlight that we
have based our design of our
uh kaplan-meier visualization on the
outcome and the findings
of a paper by morris and collaborators
that was conducted conducted among a
large number of researchers about what a
good kaplan-meier plot should look like
um and so our our couple of our plot
shows uh relevant information out of box
including things like number of patients
uh
nicely formatted access labels including
units where needed
uh as well as a data source from which
the
plot was made it also shows a risk table
in a format including things like
numbers
a number of patients at risk number of
events and number of censoring events as
well
grouped by straight um at regular time
points and this format actually follows
the recommendations by morris and
collaborators
so again um this is uh reusing
knowledge and best practice it's gonna
go to next slide
uh so how do we how do we do this uh
using this r
it's very simple we can we have two
options one is
either we plot the kepler meyer curve
alone using the first uh chunk here
um and then the risk table alone using
the second chunk here
in the middle uh and both of these show
the
the our design um philosophy of
separating the estimation from the
plotting and the styling
um but then we also have the option of
plotting all of this in one go and one
function call and it's
uh the chunk in the bottom here so this
one is just one function call and then
gives you this
that nice plot again very little code
reuses best practices and knowledge um
can we go to the next slide
so finally we have also implemented a
set of convenient estimation functions
including
including median survival times by
stratum
as well as multiple methods for testing
equality between strata
and again you can do this very easily
with only a few lines of code
and it shows you very nicely formatted
tables that follow best practices
can we go to the next slide
uh so now going into our package roadmap
i would like to um to highlight that
this is still um a prototype
so we are basically reaching now the
stage where we are uh
where we have a prototype that's um
that's reaching uh the state where it's
ready
and now we are uh reaching the stage
where we want to
launch this initiative um out there and
find
um and identify collaborators
to uh to kick start
the the next step of our project
can we go to the next slide please
and so with that i'd like to announce
that we're looking for contributors to
join with
our team uh so again bizarre is still
and
in its experimental stages uh we welcome
feedback and ideas
for features um using
github issues for example and so
actually there are two ways in which you
can contribute the first one is what we
call the open source way and so this is
the informal collaboration where you
might pick up
an issue and work on it proactively the
second way it might be the more formal
way where you reach out to us
and then we can see together if it makes
sense for you to try to join our core
team
um and so in what kind of contributions
are we looking for so we're open
to hearing your ideas in turn ask for
like design choices
project governance hands-on engineering
as well as how to maintain
an actively used package and if you want
to reach out
please reach out to mark bailey and
james black
whose emails are listed here can we go
to the next slide
uh finally i'd like to acknowledge that
we
that many other people have been
involved in the development of this
package so we would like to
thank them uh and also we have made
heavy use of open source packages
which are listed here without which this
this prototype would not have been
possible to develop
um and with that i'd like to hand over
to mark
yeah so thanks diego and thanks mark and
charlotte
that's the end of the presentation and i
guess we can start
the q a session let me start with one of
the
one of the questions that came in during
the presentations um
someone has asked are you going to open
collaborations with federal agencies
and we are working with
various other groups but more
specifically maybe mark
do you want to take this question
yeah thanks mark um we would be open to
collaborating
with anyone um this is part of a
wider set of collaborations so for
example
the the psi the the pharmaceutical
status
statistics um initiative has also
started a
special interest group on data
visualization where
a number of us are currently joined
members of and also there's
the stratos collaboration which is
related to this which is looking at
methodology as a whole for
observational data but yes we'll be open
to collaborations from
any avenues
thank you mark um another question that
came in earlier was
when will this package be on cran
yeah um yeah so i so as i said currently
it's in prototype
stages um i think we would still have to
uh probably go further into development
in order to
put it into crown uh but definitely we
have it
in our radar to do
that thank you
another question was what do you mean by
joining the core team
charlotta
thank you mark um join the court team i
guess means that at the moment we're
we're this like
relatively small group of people who had
regular meetings
um around aspects like the package
architecture for example
and while you might not want to commit
to having
those alignment meetings and other
aspects
um i guess if you joined the core team
this would be
part of like driving the general
direction of the package
making design choices and things like
that whereas if you just picked an issue
on github and contributed to it
there would be a little less involvement
in the overall direction
thank you shalotta um so there's
two questions which are uh relatively
similar one was
uh is this focusing on clinical data
only
and another question do you have a sub
team focused on reporting for
real world data so i guess overall the
question is what's the
focus of this effort
mark do you want to take that one
would say the general focus at the
moment is exploratory
analysis of clinical and medical uh data
uh i probably diego and gelato could
back me up here but they work
primarily on real world data so as a
mixture of clinical and real world data
thank you mark
a quick one was can you share
the link again to those graphical
principles i will take this one you can
see it
on this last slide
and here's another one
do you have any recommendations for
developing visualizations for different
kinds of
users users with different fluency
in data for example
diego what are your thoughts on this one
um
[Music]
the i yeah i think in general as
as mark mentioned before it's really
about
um it's really about knowing your
audience
um so i really couldn't give you like
one uh
rule of thumb for everything
but we definitely i think just in in as
for like how we are handling that with
the package
that's really part of why we have
decided to
sort of separate the idea of of doing
estimates and visualizations and like
having multiple ways of presenting um a
message
because yeah as mark said um really you
should know your audience and so
that also translates into being able to
show things in in different
or being able to communicate your
results in different ways
and so that flexibility is something
that we want to embed in our project as
well
thank you diego i'll move on to a
question regarding
um compatibility uh
two people have asked about
intentions um to combine this with latex
or somehow create a link to latex and
on the other hand um whether we are
planning to create some templates
with our for reporting with our markdown
so both of the questions maybe
can go to mark
uh yeah at the moment i guess the table
one
is an example where the engine can
change but
the underlying data or the the reporting
of the data should not change so
i do believe that um latex is an option
but hasn't been implemented i
possibly need to hand that over to
shilotto to to confirm
but we would be looking at different
engines too for reporting
yeah just to add to that actually there
was and i saw there was another question
on the chat about
gt summary so um the reason why we built
our own table rendering
was to support different engines namely
cable
gt and dt and and that is specifically
because some of these already come with
latex support
and that is implemented already at least
in a rudimentary form
regarding templates i think that's a
great idea we haven't really
we haven't really reached that stage yet
but we
we try to to create the functions at the
moment in a flexible way that allows
easy integration in in different
markdown output formats
as well as shiny
thank you mark and charlotta um
here's the question is it planned to
have
only survival analysis or other
epidemiological model or analysis i
think
the answer is clearly yes we want to
expand to many different types of
analysis
common ones and uh gradually perhaps a
little less common ones
as well
one question i think is important here
just coming in
what level of proficiency are you
looking for
in contributors maybe
shalotta do you want to answer this one
sure um i guess we're we are open for
all levels of
proficiency um so as we said this this
package is at a really early stage so
um we'd love to hear and and see people
contribute who have who have a lot of
experience in developing our packages
from which we could probably learn
quite a bit being more on the data
science and domain expert side at the
moment
but then also people who come in who
would be
like target users or who want like want
to write documentation
or vignettes are very welcome so all
levels of proficiency are welcome to
join the team
thank you very much and maybe a last
question because we only have
one minute left someone has asked about
the possibility to incorporate corporate
branding color schemes and the like on
top of the
good graphical principles the answer is
clearly yes
that's the way the package is designed
it is it should be possible to to plug
your personal or your company's
corporate branding
at the very last step on top of the
visualizations
[Music]